it's the cult hit Tron and boy do I not
want to talk about this movie not
because it's really bad or anything but
I just hate talking about the plot why
cuz it's really confusing and I don't
know if that means I'm dumb or I'm just
now computer programmer or I just have
hard typing it's I'm just kind of stuff
but man is it hard to follow but I'll
give it a shot
Flynn is a programmer who had an idea
for a video game but another person
named Dillinger stole the idea and made
millions off of it so Flynn is
determined to hack his company and see
if he can find anything to prove that he
invented the game first but little does
he know he's getting into something much
bigger than he can ever imagine and this
is where it gets a little confusing
Flynn is sucked into the world of
computers there's a whole other world
going on that apparently we don't know
about that's all going on inside our
machines programs are represented by
people digital people and they have a
theory that they're being controlled by
other people named users but there's
more of like a religion which is
actually pretty clever Flynn fights out
he has to stay in this world because
it'll please the master control program
an evil entity that's controlling
Dillinger and forcing him to get
information on the Pentagon and other
government securities obviously wanting
to take over the world of course but
Flynn does come across a friend named
Tron Tron is a security program invented
by his friend to actually stop this sort
of thing from happening from Dillinger
getting too much information or anyone
getting too much information so it seems
like he's the only one that can feasibly
stop it so do I get that right I hope I
got that right cuz men it's not easy to
transcribe I'll give the movie credit
that the set up for the story is kind of
told out of order and you do have to
think in order to follow it so it's kind
of nice that's not entirely spoon-fed to
you but since a computer age has
exploded we've gotten to know a lot of
these terms and even now it's still kind
of hard to follow now that's not to say
you can't entirely follow it you just
really got to pay attention
maybe that's why when the film first
came out it wasn't that big a hit but I
can also see why that would also be how
it got an audience over time because
there is a lot clever commentary
particularly with the religious aspect
the users are apparently controlling the
programs but the programs also have
souls of their own so who's really
controlling who there's a lot of fun
stuff that can be had with that they do
tap on it quite a bit you can tell the
majority of the time spent on this movie
is perfecting its look which while we're
at it let's talk about the look because
it is by far the best part of the movie
this film has a design that is all its
own I mean yes it's 80s yes it's bright
neon against black but at the same time
you look at this and the first thing you
think is Tron there's not really a lot
of other movies that have this specific
of design and its use of CG animation
was also groundbreaking and never really
been done to this extent before nowadays
it's pretty dated but it's still so
stylized and looks so good that you kind
of don't care you know it was the 80s
and you know it's just a product of the
times but man is it such a good looking
product of the times some of it looks a
little cheap like the costumes
themselves I don't know there's supposed
to be like neon and glowing but they
kind of look like pajamas at the time
some set pieces I think we're supposed
to look like hard metal but they look
more like cardboard but again you kind
of give it a pass because it's designed
so nicely and it is so unique and is
shot so well I love it where even when
you enter the human world you're not
entirely sure if you're in the human
world they keep going back and forth or
blending the realities and that's really
smart
again sort of playing with the idea of
who's controlling who Tron is one of
those movies where when you really think
about it is really smart and it is
really clever but you really got to take
that time to think about it in terms of
just a straightforward action-adventure
it can please people but like I said you
gotta pay close close attention to it
and I'm sure there's things that don't
add up and are never explained and real
computer programmers will probably look
at this and be like hey they forgot this
or forgot that but honestly I think
that's just the sci-fi element that's
people making stuff up for entertainment
as well as try to get whatever symbolic
point they're trying to get across I
think because I'm not a huge computer
guy I can't get into this stuff quite as
much but I do acknowledge it is a good
film it is very smart even if it is
cheesy here there
again even the designs are a little
dated but it's still something all its
own
it's a good flick and my guess is
there's a lot of people out there that
would enjoy it even more than I do it's
just a little too much going on for me
to really love but I liked it that I'm
glad I saw it but it's proven that it
does have a diehard audience and you can
see why it has a look that's all its own
it has a story that's all its own and it
is really clever yeah it can be a little
awkward as well as incredibly dated but
still when you get down to it there's
only one Tron
you